at long last ps4 owners can explore the
wonders of no man's sky but they might
run into some heavy framerate drops
during one specific part of the journey
I'm Tony and this is your galactic
gamespot news update digital foundry
posted its performance analysis of no
man's sky the game has a target of 30
frames per second on ps4 which it
consistently hits while the player is on
foot however this can drop to as low as
13 frames per second when boosting along
the surface of brand new planets digital
foundry says this is due to the game's
procedural nature but it also has a
workaround for the framerate drop simply
slow down or pull a u-turn in your ship
to let the procedural generation
complete and bring the game back up to
30fps it's a simple workaround
unfortunately the vast majority of the
game runs perfectly fine no man's sky is
out now on ps4 and the pc version
launches on august twelfth that version
may very well end up running best
depending on your rig for now you can
visit GameSpot for a shipload of no
man's sky content and for all the latest
from the video game universe you're
already in the right place